mon père était un grand homme un héros alors ils
disent que
parfois le monde n'a pas besoin d'un autre
héros parfois ce dont il a besoin est un
monstre Dracula untold est le puits l'
indice est dans le titre c'est l'
histoire inédite des origines de ce qui est le  le
personnage vampirique littéraire le plus célèbre
que nous connaissions, nous commençons l'
histoire dans les années 1400 avec l'
humain ou le personnage historique de
Vlad tepish qui a marché sur cette terre dans les
années 1460 quatorze quatorze années soixante et
il s'agit de son voyage à travers la
vie et son sacrifice  et l'agitation et les
responsabilités que beaucoup de choses qui le
font l'obligent à prendre des décisions qui ont
changé l'avenir de son peuple et de sa
famille et sa propre vie ouais je pense que
Dracula et raconté est vraiment l'histoire
de Dracula mais c'est l'histoire d'origine donc
c'est  à propos de me tirer en arrière
ce mythe et de regarder l'homme derrière
cette légende Dracula euh bien sûr je joue à la
marina, elle est la princesse et elle est
que je suppose que la boussole morale du
f  ilm, elle est la lumière directrice, elle est
mariée à Vlad et ils ont un fils
ingress et contrairement à de nombreux autres
films de vampires dans lesquels l'amour est réprimé et les
sexualités réprimées, ils commencent en quelque sorte à partir
de ce lieu d'amour pur et honnête et
c'est tous les choix qu'ils font
après ce film pour garder leur amour
ensemble
sept semaines d'entraînement en Irlande du
Nord, une incroyable équipe de cascadeurs dirigée
par m.  Buster Reeves, qui a travaillé
avec de nombreuses fois et c'est un chorégraphe fantastique,
coordinateur de cascades,
il ne peut rien faire et il m'a entraîné
tous les jours avec les cascadeurs et nous avons
eu d'énormes séquences de combat à apprendre
tellement que nous ne pouvions pas apprendre  de plus
avant de commencer à tourner le film, nous les
apprenions encore trois
mois après le début du film, je les faisais le
week-end le soir, vous savez, donc
c'était vraiment intense mais fantastique
et je voulais faire tous les combats moi-
même autant que  Je pourrais je n'ai pas
j'espère qu'il y a un Dracula inédit - ou
peut-être que ce sera Dracula dit parce que ce
ne serait pas indicible dans le second
non je ne sais pas euh
j'aimerais j'aimerais parce que je je si complètement
J'ai aimé travailler avec Luke Evans que je
signerais à peu près
tout ce qu'il ferait euh je pense que
j'aimerais voir leur histoire d'amour
explorée dans un sens contemporain un sens
du mot et je pense que c'est un
peu ce qui est  mis en place pour arriver xu  - T
qui est un devoir approprié un peu puissant
pour montrer automatiquement la chose à propos de Dracula
et je suppose que tout ce que je peux dire à ce
stade, c'est que vous savez qu'il est immortel,
il peut vivre éternellement, c'est une
figure tragique très solitaire qu'il coupe à ce stade mais
vous savez que c'est un homme qui marche dans le
temps et où nous quittons le film
ouvre très intelligemment un tout, vous savez une
passerelle d'opportunités et d'options, alors
qui sait qui sait où il ira
mais qui sait que van Helsing pourrait être une
bonne idée n'est-ce pas  ce que j'ai fait pour te sauver
alors n'oublie jamais qui je suis
toi